how are you I'm good I'm good but let's
just agree on something tonight okay
there's a certain amount a limited
amount of time that I have out here yes
so let's just agree to cut the small
talk out cut the chitchat and just get
right to the meat if you understand what
I'm saying that's incredible so no small
talk at all nothing like oh there's
there's not enough time for that
okay no maybe not on my watch okay fine
okay I hope that doesn't offend you it
doesn't offend me at all
you know mostly about 85% of my show is
just small talk and chitchat this will
hamstring me a little bit but I think I
can do it for example news big news
story big hurricane headed into Florida
yes that's very how do you feel about
talking about that well I think that's a
very important that's not like a how you
doin how's your family how's your no
house has your health yeah okay I mean
this is a difficult and a you know a
scary thing for the people that live in
Florida yeah do you have family there I
do
but again that's small talk whether
family health okay all small talk all
right yeah chitchat if you will okay and
you don't want any of that
well I like I said I only have a certain
amount of time out here to make an
impression and if you've spent so far
olynyk talking about how you don't want
any small talk no III disagree with you
I beg to differ with you I was trying to
say yeah and even that's not small talk
begging to disagree is not small talk
all right because it's interesting okay
let's talk about this fearful you look
good small talk I'll talk okay
oh this is a big story Arnold Palmer
golfing great passed away week ago you
made a bunch of commercials with Arnold
Palmer and you became friends with him
you got to know him that's right and
this is not small talk he's a legend
he's old one of the greatest of all time
and got a great guy too you know and to
get to know him was a real you know I'm
so grateful for that and this guy has
done everything you know I would tell
him I said you know Arnie he let me call
him Arnie
I said i golfed at the ocean course in
South Carolina once he goes I design
that course
I want to opens at the ocean course I
thought wow this guy's done at all yeah
and a little bit later I'd say you know
it's golfing in lanai once in Hawaii he
goes I design that course as well I won
three opens at the lanai course this guy
cannot say anything without him
yeah so I thought a couple of minutes
there said you know you know that
miniature golf course on the 405 yeah I
got there once yes I designed the
windmill not top this guy you can't do
it but but it was really fun do those
commercials and even a little bit later
I said to him what did you grow up
watching on TV he goes I love westerns
westerns was my favorite and I said I
love westerns - I grew up watching the
rifleman he goes Chuck Connors gave me
his rifle so there's nothing there's
nothing I could do but it was fun to
hang out with a mom I introduced him to
my mother and he goes oh I know your mom
hi Kathleen
I said that's probably better left
unsaid whatever happened there you know
yeah just left unsaid yeah it's a good
it's a good phrase isn't it some things
are better left unsaid yeah you hear
that every now and then yeah left unsaid
yeah like here's something better left
unsaid from farm to table you know that
expression
yes farms a big thing from farm table
yeah I know it's left unsaid what from
farm to table to toilet I will tell you
that is understood understood it doesn't
need to be on the sign better yeah yeah
in fact they could cut off the middle
just say from farm to toilet yeah
cut to the chase yeah yeah but as you
said better left unsaid better left
unsaid yeah another one of those better
left unsaid
when you're in a relationship and you
break up and you say it's not about you
it's about me but what's left unsaid
it's not about you it's about me and the
hot Pilates teacher yeah yeah yeah
better better left unsaid yeah all right
I got another one if you if you're so
excited about that the cream rises to
the top but so do dead fish
I feel this is small talk
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you